as Democrats tiptoe through the
minefields of controversy brought on by
well their most outspoken new stars
we're reminded again of one of the main
reasons that Trump won and is still
looking pretty good for 2020 his
unabashed
merican ISM America is the greatest
fighting force for peace justice and
freedom in the history of the world we
are not going to apologize for America
we are going to stand up for America no
more apologies no more apologies no more
groveling no more self-flagellating
ourselves on the world stage well as a
certain previous administration had done
in America there's a failure to
appreciate Europe's leading role in the
world instead of celebrating your
dynamic union and seeking to partner
with you to meet common challenges there
have been times where America has shown
arrogance and been dismissive even
derisively actually think that apology
is arrogant but well Trump is different
he goes over to Europe and he says hey
we value our alliance we love you guys
but it's time for NATO members to stop
free riding on the American taxpayers I
have been very very direct NATO members
must finally contribute their fair share
and meet their financial obligations but
23 of the 28 member nations are still
not paying what they should be paying
this is not fair to the people and
taxpayers of the United States imagine
that an American president in Europe
standing up for you looking out for your
hard-earned money of course the foreign
policy leads back home they shuddered
and they feel sputtered upon hearing all
of this prefering of course this
approach the United States will be
willing to acknowledge pass terror
where those errands have been made the
United States is still working through
some of our own darker periods in our
history each country must work through
its past and reckoning what the past can
help us seize a better future season a
better future is exactly what President
Trump has begun to do for America but
not by marinating and guilt over past
wrongs in public but by growing the
economy real hope Leigha Brahma Cruz
said he couldn't do it but with a crack
team of dedicated pros Trump
renegotiated old trade deals to make
them more pro-american worker and he's
holding trade cheaters like China
accountable it's about time now can you
ever imagine Kamala Harris Cory Booker
Pete Buddha judge speaking as
triumphantly as unapologetically about
American dominance and manufacturing
it's Trump today jobs are coming back
and pouring back frankly like never
before
companies are coming back into our
country they want the action production
is ramping up in the biggest way and the
awesome m1 Abrams tank is once again
thundering down the assembly line
well Trump is also unapologetic about
the government's duty to enforce our
borders and also to tailor immigration
to America's needs and values but by
contrast the Democrats they recoil from
such terms as American sovereignty and
they push instead for abolishing ice and
even abolishing the classification of
illegals as illegal we are standing on
native land and Latino people are
descendants of Native people and we
cannot be told and criminalized simply
for our identity or our status period
period well again they feel angry about
America's past and present and America
acting in America's interest oh no he
can't do that now the president was
particularly in since last week when
footage circulated a freshman
congresswoman Ilan Omar referring to
9/11 as an occasion where some people
did something so he retweeted
Omar's video and then he included clips
of the planes going into the World Trade
Center towers well the left hey of
course they weren't upset about
Omar's original comments they're mad at
Trump claiming he's the problem
endangering this woman's life Johnny's
Robert is trying to incite violence and
to divide us she does not deserve the
kind of vicious hate-filled
attacks that she's experiencing threats
on her life this is an incitement to
violence
I'm just glad someone found bado hadn't
seen him in a while well in a local
interview in Minnesota yesterday Trump
was characteristically unapologetic when
asked if he had second thoughts about
criticizing Omar the president replied
no not at all look she's been very
disrespectful to this country she's been
very disrespectful frankly to Israel
she's someone that doesn't really
understand
I think life real life what it's all
about
it's unfortunate she's got a way about
her that's very very bad I think for our
country
I think she's extremely unpatriotic and
extremely disrespectful to our country
disrespectful to our country well like a
lot of Americans agree with him
well like Obama before her Omar
reflexively apologizes for even in tone
ridiculing America for being worried
about al Qaeda
when I was in college I took a terrorism
class every time the the professor said
al-qaeda he sort of like his shoulders
went up and you know commander okay you
don't say America with an intensity you
don't say England with the intensity you
know you don't you don't say the army
with an intensity yes because we
actually recoil at evil
America and Britain we don't believe our
evil Congress on
so we bristle at that just it's off
something's off about that we bristle at
it yeah we got to be clear here she's
not alone the Democratic Party is
becoming infected with the self-loathing
quality meaning more of its members
today feel guilty about America's past
and they want to turn that guilt into
the ultimate expiation for our sins the
sins of colonialism racism misogyny etc
etc keep going and they feel justified
in tearing down history in attacking
religious symbols with deep historical
roots and even refusing to participate
in patriotic displays 2020 is shaping up
to be a showdown between more
traditional America and this new kind of
twisted vision of America no matter who
the Democratic nominee is this is the
ideological struggle before us and it's
hard right now at least to imagine that
the
can people would not again embrace the
true - city that unapologetic nature of
Trump his unwillingness to bow down to
the media and political correctness at
the moment and his determination to
protect the honor and the people of this
country his habit of standing up to the
political elite and refusing to back
down now there are words for this
approach we used to call it American
leadership and maybe we still do that's
the angle